[Music]
there is no no discussion about the fact
that we are capable of making decisions
we do
all the time that's not that's really
not under discussion the question is
whether those decisions are free
whatever that means or not
and
the feelings will stay there the
feelings are there just because the
decision is mine therefore i feel in a
certain way about my decision but then
do i really need to go on the extra step
and say yeah but is this free in a
metaphysical sense or or not
i mean people have debating of but
debated this this is this issue for
the western tradition at least for 23
2400 years
and
seems like there's only two or three
possibilities out there and it seems
like the most common one at least among
philosophers
nowadays is something called
compatibilism which is the notion that
you can have your cake and eat it too in
a sense uh that is
the universe is deterministic in the in
the bare minimum sense of we live in a
place of cause and effect there are no
miracles your decisions are not free in
the sense of being decoupled from
everything else that goes on in the
universe but at the same time they're
your decisions the position that i
explained earlier that's called
compatibilism and compatibilism is in
fact uh perfectly friendly with the
notion that we have certain emotions and
we should have certain emotions there is
no no problem with having those those
emotions we just don't need the extra
step and trying to say that those uh
decisions are ultimately free or
fundamentally free or anything like that
because that notion is metaphysically
difficult to defend in fact i think
impossible to defend
and scientifically ungrounded and so why
would why would why do we need it
i'll just bring it yes
i mean it's just i'm just i've never
debated a philosopher's before
they've harmed me
welcome to the club
how are you finding it
i mean we're talking about talking about
metaphysics and you know we i study the
brain and i look at consequential
behavior and of course we have control
of our actions what do you think what's
happening in there absolutely
philosophers and yeah what's happening i
think they're on a sort of meta level of
language which sort of is very abstract
oh it's hard stuff and it's hard
but it's not i like to look at
biological substrates of things
and i just don't think it's that
complicated yes we have moral
responsibility yes we have free will we
exercise control using our prefrontal
cortex
some of us may have stronger urges
due to gene environmental interactions
but unless you're completely impaired
and in in levels of sort of psychosis or
other things i just don't see the debate
here in this world
and we've lasted once with the whole of
philosophy
we
but so when you say i i'm generally
curious uh as a neuroscientist yeah
right uh we i think we agree that of
course that we do make decisions uh and
and oh yeah no that was never in
question right that's happened you made
the decisions but you made because of
the way you are and you're not
ultimately responsible for the way you
are right
so when you say
sorry when you say free
hey hold on oh okay okay sarah can i do
this
you were born with a certain genetics
but if i say that jeans made me do it i
am my genes or i am my brain you can't
disentangle these things sure but um but
then but you're not ultimately
responsible for what you do because you
didn't make yourself the way you are i
keep saying the same thing but
yeah i mean so you didn't in other words
let's try something different i
understand that the complex sort of play
on points but yes you are responsible i
oh yeah you're responsible in the way
that you know drinks machine is
responsible if you press the button for
a flat white right but is it is it a bit
like you know and if it doesn't give you
a flat while you push for a flat white
and it gives you a cappuccino then you
say oh there's something wrong with this
machine this machine has psychosis i
need to fix it
right no
what do you know
so okay let me go back to the second
question if i meant the question when
you say
excuse me
when you say that we have
free will yes free from what
i mean where is the freedom there i
exercise control over my brain control
can you have control
but you
you are a thing made not ultimately by
you so
but wait a minute who exercises control
over your brain
but you are responsible for your actions
because you control your actions with
your neural substrates your neural
substrates might be a complex
mixture of epigenetics and other things
but you are ultimately responsible for
your actions because you could choose
otherwise
um
did you choose your brain
you are your brain
right but you didn't choose it that you
i brain you went to brain store and
selected
no you don't need to separate these
things because you're intrinsically your
physiology
sure
then any action
that results from that you are
responsible for
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to the institute of art
and ideas at iai tv